nicolas tenzer et merci de répondre à
france 24 vous êtes politologue
professeur à sciences po et vous avez
écrit en 2011 chez perrin le monde à
l'horizon 2030 la règle et le désordre
on voit mal comment les deux parties
pourraient s'entendre comment cet
échange pourrait faire évoluer les
positions sur l'ukraine
écoutez c'est évidemment très difficile
à dire dans la mesure où l instant la
russie de poutine n'a respecté aucun des
accords quel qu'il soit qu'il s'agisse
d'abord du fameux mémorandum de budapest
de 1994 où la russie les états unis
notamment avaient signé s'il n'y avait
pas ces lieux l'ukraine rendait à ses
armes nucléaires
l'intégrité territoriale de l'ukraine
serait garanti on sait qu'il n'en a rien
été
on sait que la russie est la première
responsable de la non application des
accords de minsk et on sait également
que la russie a quand même tué environ
14000 personnes en ukraine que cette
guerre au coeur de l'europe 14
avril 6 millions personnes donc on n'a
pas aujourd'hui vladimir poutine renonce
t il veut il considère en tout cas que
l'ukraine fait partie de son territoire
à certains noms de ses conseillers lui
même l'on dit à certains moments en des
termes on ne peut plus clair donc
aujourd'hui la seule solution pour le
président joe biden s'est affiché un
discours de fermeté absolue vous avez
passé un certain nombre d'extraits
notamment tony blinken qui disait
clairement qu'il y aurait de nouvelles
sanctions on sait qu'après la rencontre
entre les deux hommes à genève un putin
hebeisen rien finalement de transit bhl
n'est sorti aujourd'hui il faut passer à
une sorte d'étape de et dire
qu'aujourd'hui il ya quelque chose
inacceptable que ce n'est pas la russie
n'ont plus qu'à décider ou non de
l'intégration future de l'ukraine dans
le temps et que l'ukraine est un pays
libre et c'est aussi un pays occupé
quand même dans le donbass et la crimée
on le sait est illégalement annexée on
va reparler de l'otan mais d'abord vous
disiez que la russie n'a pas respecté
les accords de minsk vladimir poutine
lui dit al'inverse que les ukrainiens
n'ont pas respecté non plus les accords
de minsk notamment sur
l'organisation du scrutin dans le
donbass
c'est d'être absolument impossible pour
les ukrainiens d'organiser un scrutin
dont on passe dans la mesure où le nom
de basses est occupée aujourd'hui par
les troupes russes qu'il n'y a aucun
espace possible pour la liberté que tous
les opposants à l'occupation ont été
arrêtées et certainement torturé dans un
certain nombre de prisons tenus par les
russes donc il n'ya pas de liberté ne
peut pas y avoir d'élection sincère
aujourd'hui dans le donbass donc dans
ces conditions on ne voit pas comment
l'ukraine pourrait respecter une parole
dans la mesure où les conditions en
raison de l'attitude de la russie ne
sont pas réunies vous parlez de cette
ligne rouge donc à savoir l'adhésion de
l'ukraine à l'otan est ce que ce projet
est définitivement enterrée pas vraiment
côté américain
pas vraiment côté américain du côté
européen disons que les positions sont
assez différentes en 2008 alors que le
principe de l'adhésion de l'ukraine
comme de la géorgie à l'otan avait été
acté par le sumo sommet de bucarest
aujourd'hui la france et l'allemagne
hésite hésite toujours certains
considèrent que c'est une provocation
pour la russie à mon avis ce n'est pas
le cas dans la mesure où l'otan est
quand même d'abord il faut le rappeler
une alliée à une alliance défensive et
on peut d'ailleurs penser que citant la
géorgie que l'ukraine avait été membre
de l'otan en 2008 l'invasion de sept
pays n'aurait pas eu lieu donc
aujourd'hui c'est une garantie
essentielle de sécurité lors ce n'est
pas à l'ordre du jour on parle souvent
de ce qu'on appelle une marque c'est à
dire un document qui permet l'adhésion
de ces pays qui ne sont certainement pas
encore mûrs et je pense qu'on ne peut
pas dire que l'adhésion à l'otan doivent
être décidés à moscou ce n'est pas une
provocation envers la russie c'est
justement une 40 hits sécurité si la
russie n'avait pas une attitude
agressive et bien je pense que il y
aurait aucun problème de son côté à ce
que l'adhésion de ces pays à l'otan
puisse être actée descola tenzer est-ce
que la russie selon voix a l'intention
de passer à l'acte dont vers l'ukraine
quelle en serait son intérêt
c'est extrêmement difficile à dire pour
l'instant a surtout l'impression que
moscou test la résolution des puissances
occidentales
que ce soit les états unis ou l'union
européenne il y a affectivement cette
menace directe qui voudraient en tout
cas dans l'esprit de moscou conduire à
ce que à nouveau les occidentaux cède
mais je crois que là c'est véritablement
un point de non-retour donc on ne s'est
certainement pas quelles sont les
intentions russes est une possibilité ce
n'est certainement pas une certitude on
sait que d'ailleurs dans l'intérêt de la
russie ce serait certainement pas bon
qu'il y ait une guerre aussi offensives
mais je pense que c'est une possibilité
et qu'il faut très clairement marqué que
c'est une ligne rouge absolue il faut
quand même rappeler que jusqu'à présent
depuis l'arrivée de poutine au pouvoir
en 2000 pour l'instant poutine a
toujours réussi à faire céder les
occidentaux il nous avait eu 20 % du
territoire de la géorgie qui a été
conquis en quelque sorte par la russie
la lections illégale de la crimée la
vase ion du donbass de fait la rentrée
complète du bélarus dans la sphère
russes les crimes de guerre massifs
commis par la russie en syrie avec pour
l'instant extraordinairement peu de
sanctions à l'égard de ce pays en tout
cas pas des sanctions suffisante pour
arrêter la puissance russe donc je pense
que pour l'instant poutine a gagné ses
différentes guerres aujourd'hui je pense
qu'il est temps de dire cela doit
s'arrêter nicolas tenzer sur france24
merci beaucoup je rappelle le titre de
votre ouvrage le monde à l'horizon 2030
la règle et le désordre